[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا في اخبار الساعه من
العربيه نستعرض ونرصد معكم ابرز المستجدات
الى العناوين
القوات الروسيه تقترب من حسن معركه بخموت
وزعيم فاجنر يدعو زيلينسكي لاخراج
المدنيين
وزير الدفاع امريكا في جوله شرق اوسطيه
والبنتاجون لا يستبعد الخيار العسكريه ضد
ايران
وسط تمديد دولي دعوات لاحتجاجات واسعه ضد
النظام الايراني بسبب مسلسل تسمم فتيات
المدارس
الصين تدعو لاعاده التوحيد السلمي مع
تايوان والاخيره ترد بضروره احترام حريه
شعبها
اهلا بكم البدايه من تطورات الحرب
الاوكرانيه اذ تحتدم المعارك في مخموت ما
بين اوكرانيا وروسيا منذ سبعه اشهر وفي
اخر التطورات الميدانيه قالت هيئه الاركان
العامه للقوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه ان
القوات الروسيه لا تزال تحاول محاصره ضخمه
دون جدوى مضافه ان المدافعين عن المدينه
صدو العديد من الهجمات داخل المدينه وفي
محيطها من جهته صرح مؤسس قوات فاجنر
يفغيني بيجوجين ان روسيا قادره على تطبيق
بالكامل لكنهم يدعون الرئيس الاوكراني الى
منح كبار السن والاطفال فرصه لمغادره
المدينه
تستعر المعارك في الشرق الاوكراني بعد
تعزيزات موسكو العسكريه لمحور دانيت الذي
شهد تقدما للقوات الروسيه في ظل انتقادات
مؤسسي مجموعه فاجنر القتاليه لمسار
المعارك التي تديرها الدفاع في محاور
عديده ذلك بعد ان حقق مقاتلوا فاجنر نجاحا
املموسا شمال المقاطعه في مدينه
نحن نرسل مجموعه اخرى من المقاتلين
الاوكرانيين الى ديارهم والذين قاتلوا
بشجاعه ثم قتلوا وزير الدفاع الروسي
ظهر فجاه في ميدان معارك دانيت كرد منه
على اتهامات بريجوجن الذي قال ان الضباط
الروس لا يعرفون شيئا عن مجرى المعارك
واوضاع الجنود مطالبا بتحميلهم مسؤوليه
الاخطاء
ننتظر منكم انجازات جديده وننتظر تحقيق
اهداف الخطط التي وضعناها لان جهدنا هام
جدا لوطننا رغم الارهاصات العديده التي
تشهدها العمليه العسكريه الروسيه الا ان
تنافسا كبيرا انطلق بين القاده الروس من
اجل تقديم انجازات ملموسه لسيد الكريلم
انعكس نقصد ذخيره والسلاح عند القوات
الاوكرانيه خلال الاسابيع الماضيه على
مسار المعارك في العمليه العسكريه
ذلك ما ادى الى انخفاض وتيره القصف
الاوكراني على مناطق الانفصاليين في دمباس
لقناتي العربيه والحدث رائد الاغبر
دانياسك
اذا تقارير الان تتحدث عن تعرض طالبات في
اربعه مدارس للتسمم في محافظه زنجان
الايرانيه صباح اليوم وهذا سيكون موضوع
اساسي وملف رئيس معنا وسيكون معنا ضيف
حوله تجري شركه رايمان الالمانيه لصناعه
الاسلحه محادثات واعيده لبناء مصنع دبابات
في اوكرانيا حيث قال رئيس الشركه ارمين
باي برجر ان تكلفه بناء مصنع دبابات تبلغ
نحو 200 مليون يورو لانتاج ما يصل الى 400
دبابه من طراز بانثر سنويا واضاف انه
يتوقع اتخاذ قرار بشان هذا المخطط خلال
شهرين موضحا ان موقعا مماثلا يمكن حمايته
من هجوم الروسي بواسطه منظومه دفاع جوي
وهدد الرئيس الروسي السابق ونائب رئيس
مجلس الامن القومي ديمتري ميدفادف بان
يواجه افتتاح هكذا مصنع يواجه بوابل من
صواريخ كاليفر ومن دنياه ينضم الينا مراسل
العربيه رائد الاغبر اهلا بك رائد يعني
تطورات الوضع ببخ موت في ظل يعني معلومات
متضاربه ان كان من الجانب الاوكراني تصر
على انه القوات الاوكرانيه ما زالت تقاوم
حتى اخر لحظه ومعلومات من الجانب الروسي
وقواد فاغنر بانه تقريبا
باخموت تم السيطره عليها ومحاصرتها
صباح الخير راويه بالفعل يعني الجانب
الروسي والجانب الاوكراني يؤكدون بان
القوات الاوكرانيه ما زالت تقاوم في مدينه
باخموت بالامس يعني
الذين قتلوا وارسلهم هم قاتلوا بشجاعه
لكنهم قتلوا ذلك في اشاره منه الى السيطره
الروسيه او سيطره قواته الخاصه على
المنطقه بالفعل قوات فاجنر طوقت مدينه
باخموت من النواحي الثلاث وتبقى الطريق
الوحيد في المنطقه الغربيه
بلدتي خرومافا وبغدانا حتى الان معارك
ضاريه في هذا المحور لكن لم يستطع الجيش
الروسي اختراقها تاني البلدان القوات
الاوكرانيه تدافع من هذا المحور الغربي
وصولا الى منتصف المدينه دخلت القوات
الروسيه في العمق سيطرت على احياء كثيره
عده كيلومترات هي المدينه صغيره اصلا دخلت
عده كيلومترات من جميع النواحي وصولا الى
المنتصف لم تستطع اختراق قلب المدينه الذي
يمتد للناحيه الغربيه وما زالت القوات
الاوكرانيه تسيطر على هذه المناطق وهو
الطريق الوحيد كما وصفه
بانه يمكن للقوات الاوكرانيه الانسحاب من
هنا كاشاره الى ان المهله التي منحها قائد
قوات فاغنر
للانسحاب خلال يومين انتهت وعاده المعارك
لتستعر اكثر ولتكون اعنف واكثر الشراسه في
هذا المحور رائد يعني دعنا نذكر بانه اذا
سيطرت القوات الروسيه على بخموت ما الذي
ستستفيده ميدانيا اتحدث تحديدا عن
الامدادات خطوط الامداد كيف ستستفيد من
ذلك وايضا لاحقا ما المناطق او المدن التي
يمكن ان تصبح سهله السيطره عليها
بالفعل مدينه باخمت ليس لها ذات الاهميه
يعني
الماديه المقصود ليس فيها كنوز من الالماس
او الذهب او المصانع كما في مناطق اخرى في
دمباس او الحديد هي عباره عن مناجم للملح
ومصانع للكحول لكن الاهميه الاستراتيجيه
للمدينه لانها هي الحصن المانع امام المدن
الكبرى كراماتورسك
واسلافيانس وكذلك
قسطنطينه هذه المدن هامه جدا وهي الاكبر
في المحور الشمالي من المقاطعه كما ان نهر
هو الاكثر اهميه لايصال المياه العذبه الى
مناطق دمباس حيث تحتجزها القوات
الاوكرانيه خلف مدينه سلافيا سلافيان اذا
سيطر الجيش الاوكراني على يكون قد فتح
البوابه للمواجهه الرئيسيه مع هذه المدن
حيث تكمن هنا قواعد عسكريه كبيره للقوات
الاوكرانيه الجانبين يعرفون
بان مدينه باخمت ليست مهمه لتلك الغايه
لكن مجرد السيطره عليها يجعل مواجهه اكبر
واقرب ما بين القوى الاكبر من قبل الجيش
الاوكراني والجيش الروسي شكرا جزيلا لك
رائد الاخبار من دانياسك وينضم الينا من
كياف العاصمه الاوكرانيه حذيفه عاد اهلا
بك حذيفه يعني كانت اوكرانيا اعلنت منذ
قرابه الساعه عن تاهب جوي في سبع مقاطعات
تحسبا لغارات روسيه وكان هناك ايضا حديث
لهيئه الاركان الاوكرانيه عن انه
تحديثات بما يخص محاولات القوات الروسيه
وفاجنر الدخول الى باخموت
نعم تحياتي في الحقيقه لا يدور الحديث
ابدا عن اي معارك داخل ضخمه في داخل مدينه
باقمت هذا بحسب السلطات الاوكرانيه وهيئه
الاركان المشتركه العامه الاوكرانيه وكذلك
قوات القوات العامه القياده العملياتيه في
الشرق الحديث يدور عن القتال في محور
باخوت يقول شريفاتي وهو الناطق الرسمي
باسم القوات المقاتله في الشرق يقول ان
هنالك السيطره تامه وتحصين تام للمدينه في
داخل المدينه وفي ضواحي المدينه الحديث
الان يدور عن محاولات للهجوم في شمال
المدينه
وفي جنوب غرب المدينه وكذلك من الشمال في
اتجاه الغرب قليلا هنالك فيفوكا وايفانا
وايضا بعض القرى الصغيره يعني حوالي ثلاثه
او اربعه قرى في تلك المنطقه في الشمال
وهنالك محاوله للزحف قليلا الى الغرب
لمحاوله الحصار الكامل ولكن حتى هذه
اللحظات تؤكد القوات الاوكرانيه ان انها
ما زالت تسيطر على المدينه كذلك ميخائيل
بودلاك وهو مستشار الرئيس فلاديميراسكي
كان قد اعلن عن ان هنالك نعم قد قامت
القوات الروسيه بتدمير الجسر الذي عقد
عمليه الامداد للقوات الاوكرانيه داخل
المدينه ولكن ايضا قال ان هنالك طرق بديله
وما زالت الامداد تصل الى داخل المدينه
والوضع مستقر حتى هذه اللحظه كذلك معهد
الدراسات الحرب الامريكي ايضا يعني نشر
ملخص حول الوضع الان في مدينه باغوت اولا
بدا هذا الملخص وقال ان لا يمكن للقوات
الروسيه هي لا تحقق النجاح الذي يخولها
لاعكمال عمليه الحصار في المستقبل القريب
كما قالوا وهذا انا هنا اخذ نصا ما قالوه
وايضا ان القتال ما زال يدور ان القوات
الاوكرانيه ما زالت قادره على ايصال
الامدادات كذلك تحدث نائب عمده المدينه
بالامس يعني في وقت متاخر عن الخسائر داخل
المدينه وقال انه يعني نتيجه القصف قتل
مواطنين في داخل المدينه كذلك قتلت امراه
واصيبه رجلان في محاوله للخروج من المدينه
كانوا يحاولون الخروج لذلك في الوقت
الحالي لا يمكن باي شكل من الاشكال
للمدنيين الذين بقوا في المدينه وهم حوالي
اربعه الى خمسه الاف مواطن الخروج من
المدينه على في سيارات لان القوات الروسيه
تستهدف السيارات الداخله والخارجه من
المدينه لذلك المواطنين الان الذين يتخذون
القرار بعمليه الاجلاء هم يخرجون على
اقدامهم وهي مسافه طويله جدا تعلمين ان
الجو بارد جدا خاصه في الشرق ولكنهم
يحاولون الخروج طبعا للحفاظ على حياتهم
ويسيرون لعده كيلومترات للخروج من هذه
المدينه ولكن حتى هذه اللحظه تؤكد السلطات
حتى الرئيس اكد ان القوات ما زالت تسيطر
وايضا يعني يقول ما احد دراسات الحرب انه
اذا
اتخذ القرار من قبل القوات المسلحه
الاوكرانيه بالخروج من المدينه وتسليمها
فه سيكون بشكل استراتيجي ولن يكون عشوائي
ولديها الوقت ولديها المساحه لتفعل ذلك
ولكن حتى هذه اللحظه لم يتخذ القرار
قال ان الوضع يحتاج الى كثير من الذخائر
وكثير من القذائف لذلك ينتظرون طبعا
الامدادات ولكن حتى هذه اللحظه القوات
الاوكرانيه قادره كما تقول على السيطره
خاصه في الخطوط الاماميه وكذلك قائد كتيبه
وهي كتيبه الحريه التي تقاتل في مخك
متاكده ايضا ذلك انهم يسيطرون على مواقعهم
وما زالوا يحافظون عليها شكرا جزيلا لك
مراسل العربيه
افادت الحكومه الاوكرانيه بانها ستستخدم
الاصول الروسيه المصادره لاعاده بناء
البلاد والتعويض مواطنيها وقال رئيس
الوزراء الاوكراني دانيل ان الاصول التي
تمت مصادرتها من البنوك الروسيه تزيد
قيمتها عن 460 مليون دولار وان الحكومه
تعمل مع الحلفاء لتطوير نظام قائم على
معاهده دوليه لتساعد في تحديد كيفيه اصدار
تعويضات للاوكرانيين قال المرشح الرئاسي
والرئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب انه
بامكانه انهاء الحرب الكارثيه بين روسيا
واوكرانيا على حد وصفه مشددا على ان حل
النزاع بين الولدين لن يستغرق منه اكثر من
يوم واحد
قبل ان نصل الى البيت الابيض سوف اقوم
بتسويه الحرب الكارثيه بين روسيا
واوكرانيا وستتم تسويتها بسرعه
احزاب المعارضه التركيه تتاهب لاعلان
مرشحها لمواجهه اردوغان فسبق الرئاسيه
اهلا بكم من جديد ونواصل هذه النشره من
السباق الرئاسيه التركي الذي بدا مبكرا
اذا افاد مراسل العربيه في تركيا بان
احزاب المعارضه التركيه ستعلن عن مرشحها
المشترك لرئاسه يوم الاثنين ياتي ذلك بعد
ان جدد خمسه زعماء بقينا في تحالف
المعارضه التركيه التزامهم بمبادئه
التاسيسيه بعد ان انسحبت زعمه الحزب
الصالح من التحالف اثر خلاف حول المرشح
للانتخابات الرئاسيه حيث اشار البيان
الخماسي الى ان ائتلاف مصمم هذا الائتلاف
مصمم على مواصله عمله في نفس الاتجاه
تمشيا مع مبادئه واهدافه التاسيسيه في
السياق ذاته اكد الرئيس التركي رجب طيب
اردوغان ان حزب العداله والتنميه الحاكم
وحليفه القومي يتمسكان بمواصله مسارهما
بعد انقسام التحالف المعارضه حول مرشحه
للرئاسه في الانتخابات العامه المقرره في
منتصف مايو المقبل وقال انهم كانوا
يتوقعون حدوث ذلك قبل الشهور لكن حزب
حدد هدفه وهو ماض في العمل على خريطه
الطريق الخاصه بهم من جهته اشار زعيم
المعارضه كمال كليتش دور اوغلو الى ان
احزاب اخرى ستنضم للتحالف في اعقاب انسحاب
حزب الجيد ثاني اكبر احزاب المعارضه في
البلاد من تكتل الطاوله السداسيه
طبعا لا شك ان زلزال تركيا سيخلف ارتدادات
في المشهد السياسي بالبلاد قبل شهرين من
الانتخابات الحاسمه حيث تريد غالبيه
الاطراف توظيف ما حصل في حملاتها
الانتخابيه ويبدو حزب العداله والتنميه
ورئيسه اردوغان في عين العاصفه لا سيما
بعد الحديث عن قصور في عمليات الاستجابه
خلال الايام الاولى لوقوع الكارثه
شهران ونصف تفصل تركيا عن استحقاق هو
الاهم منذ عقود انتخابات الرئاسيه
وبرلمانيه سترسم معها مستقبل البلاد
ومستقبل رجب طيب اردوغان الرئيس الذي تصدر
المشهد منذ عقدين في خضم استعدادات الجميع
للحدث الابرز جاءت كارثه الزلزال المدمر
لتلقي بظلالها على الاستحقاق الانتخابي
وعلى الاطراف السياسيه الفاعله في البلاد
ولا شك على حزب العداله والتنميه ورئيسه
اردوغان
هناك العديد من الاستبيانات التي قالت ان
شعبيه الحزب الحاكم تراجعت بنسبه 13% خلال
العام رغم الجهود التي بذلوها كزياده الحد
الادنى للاجور وتخفيض سن التقاعد لكن بعد
زلزال باتت الحكومه في وضع اصعب من الوضع
الذي كانت عليه
الشركات ابحاث عديده نش تقاريرها عن نسبه
تاييد الناخبين للاحزاب السياسيه في تركيا
لا شك ان بعض هذه التقارير اشارت الى
تراجع طفيف في شعبيه الحزب الحاكم وبعضها
الاخر اشار الى ارتفاع طفيف في نسبه تاييد
الحزب بالشارع لكن تقريبا كل التقارير
والدراسات ما زالت تعطي اردوغان افضليه
على منافسيه
يوجد خوف لدى الحكومه وهذا واضح خوف من
فكره ان يؤثر الزلزال على الانتخابات لذلك
هناك محاولات مثلا لتامين البيوت يحاولون
تغيير هذه الظروف السلبيه وهذا يجب ان
يؤخذ بعين الاعتبار لكن بالعموم لا شك ان
الزلزال اكثر سلبا على الحكومه التوقعات
بعد الزلزال ذهبت الى ان حكومه اردوغان
ستدفع ثمن تقصيرها في التعاطي مع ازمه
الزلزال
على الساعات والايام الاولى بصناديق
الاقتراع لكن الرياح السياسه في معسكر
المعارضه هبت بما يشتهيه اردوغان ويتمناه
ميرال اكشنر زعيمه حزب الخير تنقلب على
تحالف الطاوله السداسيه في سيناريو يبعد
المعارضه بشكل اني عن احتمالات الفوز لكن
احتمالات تماسك من بقي في هذا التحالف ما
زالت قائمه والمشهد قد يتغير بين لحظه
واخرى هزات الزلزال في جنوب تركيا انتقل
صداها الى العاصمه انقره وخيمت على المشهد
السياسي ويبدو انها ستلقي بظلالها الثقيله
على اردوغان وحسبه الا اذا غرقت المعارضه
اكثر في خلافاتها ولم تستطع تجاوز ازمتها
الراهنه زيدان زنجلو العربيه اسطنبول
اتزال ارتدادات الزلزال التي ضرب تركيا
تدوي وتتلاحق على رقعه المدن المنكوبه
وتتجاوزها الى وسط وشمال البلاد اداره
الطوارئ والكوارث التركيه افاد اكدت وقوع
حوالي 13 الف هزه ارتداديه منذ السادس من
فبراير هذا التاريخ المفصلي بالنسبه
لتركيا وايضا لشمال سوريا ستعود اليه
الزميله حنين الشولي في محاكاه تروي فيها
قصه الزلزال من البدايه
احدى ليالي الشتاء الطويل
ابردها السادس من فبراير درجه الحراره صفر
بالضبط
تحت سقف البيت الدافئ احلام بغد يشبه
الامس
لم يكن افضل
انها الرابعه
وسبعه عشره دقيقه
هل هذا حلم ايضا
ليس دوارا
انها هزه مستمره
لا تتوقف
حتما ستوقد الجميع
دقيقه واربع ثواننا كسرت كل شيء الزمن
الاحلام والمستقبل
اخذت الامنينه من النوم الى الموت في
المخاض الانقاض قبل انتشال ثلاثه واربعين
الفا وخمسمائه منهم جثثا هامتا
هي دقيقه زلزال ضخم بقوه
7.8 درجات على مقياس ريختر وهنا في غازي
عنتاب في نورداك حجم الكارثه لا يصدق
اختفت ملامح الحي وكان الزلزال وقع على
سطح الارض صحيح نسبيا عمقه كان 18 كيلو
متر وهذه البقعه حيث اقف ليست المركز او
البؤره
الكارثه وقعت في بازرجيك شمالي المحافظه
في كهرمان مرعش المنكوبه وسنعلم لاحقا ان
نكبتها ستحل على عشر مقاطعات جنوبيه اخرى
امتد اثر الزلزال اليها ليدمر اكثر من 105
الاف مبنى على 500 كم
زلزال لا ليس بعد هذه هزه ارتداديه بقوه
6.4 درجات ستاتي على المزيد من المباني
والارواح سيليها اكثر
سبعه الاف
ومئتي هزه
لكن الزلزال الاول كان بقوتي
خمسمائه قنبله نوويه
كانها لم تكن يوما مدينه تبدل ضجيج الحياه
بصرخات الموت يسمعها الناجون كما
المحاصرون بالردم في كل مكان
والبستان المدمره على موعد مع الضربه
الثانيه تمحي حكاياتي واثر كبار وصغار لا
يزالنا تحت اثر وهول الصدمه الاولى
انها الواحده واربع وثلاثون دقيقه ظهرا
لا سوف يعلو الان على صوت جرافات تزيح
انقاد وركام بيوت ابتلعت سكانها واخرى
تهدم ما تبقى من خرسانه عرضتها ثنائيه
الزلزلين والفساد مصيرها الانهيار عاجلا
ام اجلا 50 الف مبنى واكثر من هذا المكان
والزمان بات الوقت يقاس بخساره الارواح
سباق مع الموت لكبح العداد المفجع للوفيات
المؤكده واخر مع الصقيع وتدني الحراره
ليلا الى خمسه عشره درجه تحت الصفر تحديدا
في البستان
وللمفقودين عداد اخر لا يوثقه سوى الناجين
وشهاداتهم بمن ترك خلفهم دون حظ
او رائحه
هكذا سجلت لحظات الموت وقليل من البطوله
عليه فرق انقاذ محليه ودوليه من 90 دوله
استنفذت كل ادواتها ولكل
معداته التقنيه والتقليديه المجربه
والخاضعه للاختبار الجيران المدربه على
كشف الالغام في افريقيا حضرت من بلجيكا
على الرقعه التركيه المنكوبه بحقيبه ظهر
وكاميرات لترصد من شقوق الركام وفسحاته
الضيقه صوتا او حركه المرجوه
345 الف شقه سكنيه استنسخ قدر ساكنيها
ولربما كان مصيرهم الحياه لو كانت هذه
الصوره الطبقيه الافتراضيه توفرت واقعيا
لمجدتهم غير ان الصور من باطن الارض الى
علو السماء لا تنقذوا ارواحا سبقها سيف
الوقت
واخطاء الاغاثه والاستجابه المتاخره فمن
ظن في ظلمه الركان لانه
اخطا الصوره تزداد قتامه من ارتفاع تحنيق
المسيرات او هكذا يراد منها برصدها حجم
الضرر الذي حل باكثر من 26 مليون شخص خمسه
عشر مليون في تركيا واحد عشر مليون متضرر
تفصلهم الحدود الجنوبيه على الجانب الاخر
البؤس لن يكون مؤقتا والواقع لا يغيره
تاريخ ولا مفاجات او كوارث طبيعيه ان كانت
نورداك اصلاحيه بزرجيك البستان وانطاكيا
في تركيا الاكثر تاثرا فعنوان مقاس
الكارثه بوقعها الاعنف تجلى في جنديرس
عفرين سلقين حارم وجبله السوريه
النجوم منهم مصيرهم العراء الدائم غالبا
او المغلف بخيام تاخرت لن ينسى منهم من
تبقت لديه رفاهيه الذكرى ان اولى قوافل
النجده الشحيحه المنقوصه دخلت مناطقهم بعد
اليوم الخامس من وقوع الكارثه يعيش خمسه
ملايين ونصف المليون السوري مع خذلانا قتل
كذلك عددا يبقى غير معلوم
ما نعلمه ان نحو سبعه الاف شخص قضى تحت
انقاض مباني انتهتكت بفعل القصف المكثر
لسنوات
وتوقف البحث عن المزيد لنقص المعدات
والارض هنا بما يفوق الحصيله غير المؤكده
للضحايا
احتضنت المزيد
20300 اعادتهم كارثه الزلزال من رحله
لجوهم الى تركيا
جثثا هامده
بين السياسي والانساني كثير من المفارقات
وانتشابه مسرحات دمار وتوحدت صيحه الالم
ان كانت تحديات تركيا مرغونه بالوقت في
الاسعاف والانقاذ وانتشال الجثث ومن ثم
اعاده الاعمار بتكلفه تقدر ب 100 مليار
دولار
فاقارب الساعه
لملايين السوريين احياء وامواتا في عهده
الزلزال توقفت عند الرابعه
عشره دقيقه فجر السادس من فبراير 2000
شهدت مدن عده في ايران احتجاجات نظمتها
عائلات الفتيات التي تعرضنا للتسمم في بعض
المدارس فيما سجلت حالات التسمم المزيد من
الاعداد لطالبات في خمس محافظات بينما لا
يزال الغموض يلف القضيه التي اثارت القلق
والغضب واشار موقع ايران انترناشونال الى
خروج مواطنين فاحتجاجات امام مباني وزاره
التربيه والتعليم بمختلف المدن بما في ذلك
طهران وصفهان وكرمانشاه واردبيل وادانوا
خلالها اتساع ظاهره تسمم الطالبات ورفعوا
شعارات ضد المرشد علي خامنئي وكبار
المسؤولين في البلاد ونشر الموقع عبر
تويتر مقطع فيديو قال انه يظهر احتجاز
مسؤولي مدرسه بمدينه نسيم شهر التابعه
لمحافظه طهران الطالبات المصابات بالتسمم
داخل المدرسه لاسباب مجهوله واظهر مقطع
اخر تعرض مدرستين للبنات لهجوم كيميائي في
مدينه همدان وكذلك في مدينه كرمانشا غربي
البلاد بحسب الموقع
[موسيقى]
وبينما يستمر مسلسل التصميم في مدارس
ايران خلال الاشهر الثلاثه الفائته دعت
نقابه المعلمين في محافظه كيلان جميع
المعلمين الى التجمع يوم الثلاثاء المقبل
صباحا امام المديريه العامه للتعليم في
هذه المحافظه كما اعلن وزير الداخليه
الايراني احمد وحيد لان الاجهزه الامنيه
تتابع قضيه تسمم الطالبات في عده مدارس
بالبلاد بعدما افادت التقارير اعلاميه
باتساع نطاق الاحتجاجات بهذا الشان في
اكثر من مدينه لتشمل العاصمه طهران وصفهان
وكرمانشه وقال ان محققين عثروا على عينات
مشبوهه واشار الى ورود تقارير عن حدوث
المضاعفات في اكثر من 50 مدرسه
موجه تسمم تجتاح مدارس الفتيات في ايران
تقارير اعلاميه ايرانيه افادت بالتعرض
طالبات للتسمم في اكثر من 50 مدرسه وثنويه
بمزيج من غازات سامه وارسال عدد كبير منهن
الى المستشفيات
الطالبات تسممنا عن طريق الاستنشاق
ويعانين من اعراض الغثيان والضعف والدوار
والسعال وضيق التنفس
قناه ايران انترناشونال افادت باتساع نطاق
الاحتجاجات على تسمم الطالبات في اكثر من
مدينه لتشمل العاصمه طهران واصفهان
وكرمنشاه واردبيل
صحه الطالبات تمثل الاولويه القصوى
والاجهزه الامنيه تتابع قضيه تسممين وقد
عثرت على عينه مشبوهه في عده مدارس في
البلاد هذا ما اعلنه وزير الداخليه
الايراني احمد وحيدي
ثلاثه اشهر مرت على سلسله عمليات التسمم
التي تعرضنا لها الطالبات ولم يتم التعرف
على منفذي الهجمات قوات الامن الايراني
اعتقلت عددا من الاسر التي تجمعت امام
مبنى وزاره التربيه والتعليم قبل ترحيل
بعضهم الى سجن ايفين
حول قضيه تسميم الفتيات في المدارس
الايرانيه ينضم الينا هنا في الاستوديو
الباحث في الشان الايراني صالح حميد اهلا
بك السيد صالح معنا في استديوهات الرياض
يعني بعد ثلاثه اشهر من الصمت الرسمي
الايراني الان هناك حديث عن تحقيقات امنيه
ولكن لا يوجد تفسير لا من وزاره التربيه
ولا يوجد يعني تفسير من مبادراء المدارس
حول مثلا اذا كان هذا السم هو من الاكل هو
من غاز هذا اللبس كيف يمكن تفسيره صحيح
يعني كل هذا الغموض هو الذي يدفع بتعزيز
شكوك والتهم ضد السلطات بالتواطئ مع
الفاعلين دعينا ابدا بالاحصائيات الان
اليوم تكشف ان هذه الهجمات التي بات
يوصفها الكثير بهجمات كيماويه او بيولوجيه
شمل الثلاثه وثلاثين مدينه في سبعه عشر
محافظه ايرانيه اي اكثر من نصف مساحه
البلاد
يعني باتت ظاهره خطيره دفعت بالاهالي
لتجمعات عديده امام وزاره التعليم امام
البرلمان امام المدارس وبالطبع السلطات
ليس لديها حل سوى الحل المعهود وهو الحل
الامني الصمت وزير الداخليه الذي كلف
بمتابعه الموضوع وفتح تحقيق قال ان هناك
يعني عينات تحت
الاختبار والفحص وستعلن النتائج لاحقا لكن
البيانات التي صدرت من عدد من الشخصيات
بما فيها بيان اليوم من مجمع
مدرسي الحوزه الدينيه في قوم اشار بوضوح
الى انها هجمات كيماويه بيولوجيه منظمه
هذا يذكرنا بسوابق مشابهه لتعامل النظام
مع هكذا قضايا ويتهم بها افراد ما يسميهم
بمجموعات متشدده ومارقه ايقافها صالح يعني
السلطات التي يعني تقول بانها تجري
تحقيقات لا تعطي حلولا وهذه الهجمات او
حالات التسمم كما تقول هجمات كيماويه حسب
المعلومات لم تتوقف حتى الان تلم الحلول
المطروحه يعني هذه نفس طريقه تعاطي
السلطات مع هجمه مع ظاهره الهجمات بالسيده
والحمض ضد النساء قبل سنوات ولم تسفر
التحقيقات عن اي شيء ولم يتم الكشف عن
الفاعلين او اعتقالهم لذلك الان
النشط والكثير من الخبراء وحتى بعض نواب
مجلس شورى يقولون ان هذه الهجمات هي هجمات
انتقاميه ضد النساء لانه شعار هذه
الاحتجاجات كان المراه الحياه الحريه
وكانت هناك مشاركه واسعه للنساء فالنظام
يريد ان يبث الرعب والخوف من جهه ومن جهه
اخرى يحرف الانظار عن الاحتجاجات الشعبيه
تجاه هذه القضيه والكثير يقولون ان هذه
المجموعات التي يوصف بالاصوليه المتشدده
مثلا محمد تقي فاضل ما يبدي احد الكبار
المراجع قال ان هذه مجموعه صغيره اصوليه
متجدده متنفذه في النظام تسمى بالفارسيه
هزاري الالفيه الجديده وهؤلاء يعتقدون
بانه يجب حرمان النساء والفتيات من
التعليم وافكارهم
سيد صالح وكنت ذكرت عن مطالبات من
برلمانيين هناك مطالبات من برلمانيين
بلجنه لتقصي الحقائق حول هذه القضيه ولكن
هل النظام
سيصغي ربما الى هذه المطالبات لا نعلم
هناك مراقبين كما ذكرت يتحدثون انه هذه
الطريقه ربما هي لالهاء الشعب الايراني عن
الاحتجاجات التي يعني هي اكثر ما يقلق هذا
النظام ووجوده ام انه ترى هدف تسميم
الفتيات هو
ايدولوجيه هذا النظام التي لا تشجع على
تعليم الفتيات هي المشكله انه لدى هذا
النظام الطابق في التعاطي ذكرنا قضيه
الهجمات ضد النساء بالاسيد نذكر ايضا قضيه
استهداف الطائره الاوكرانيه وكيف ان
النظام يستهدف طائره مدنيه وقتل 176 راكب
بهدف منع حدوث اي نظام عندما استهدف قاعده
عين الاسد الامريكيه في العراق لذلك قبل
ذلك في التسعينات بالعهد الرئيس خاتمه
ايضا كانت هناك هجمات متسلسله لاختيارات
العلماء والمثقفين والكتاب المعروفين
الذين كانوا يريدون تغييرات اصلاحيه في
البلاد كل هذه
الظواهر تعاطى معها النظام بتحقيقات شكليه
بتصريحات مندده من اعلى سلطه ولكن بتواطئ
من الاجهزه الامنيه وربما يتم التضحيه
باشخاص
على سبيل المحاكمتهم او ادانتهم بهذه
القضاء ولكن لا يتم حل القضيه بشكل جذري
اي الكشف عن الفاعلين التفاصيل هذا يقف
فرعها لذلك هذه تشكك
تعزز
التشكيك والاتهام للسلطات بالتواضع مع هذه
ولكن اود ان يعني بكلمه اخيره اذا ما الحل
الافضل لمواجهه حالات التسمم وايضا ما
يرتكبه النظام بحق شعبه هل الاستمرار في
الاحتجاجات النظام طبعا يستمر بالقمع
بالمقابل الناس والاهالي لانها يعتبرون
هذه هجمات تستهدف امن البنات والطلاب لذلك
الان شاهدنا تجمعات وهناك دعوه في يوم 8
مارس اليوم العالمي للمراه للتجمعات حاشده
على مستوى ايران كافه شكرا جزيلا لك سيد
صالح حميد الباحث في الشان الايراني
[موسيقى]
نعت الناشطه الايرانيه شيرين عبادي الطفل
الامير علي موسى وي البالغ من العمر عامين
بعد ان قتل برصاص القوات الامنيه الخاصه
على طريق اصفهان بعد ان اعترضت شاحنه
تابعه لقوات النظام طريق العائله واطلقت
ناره نحوهم دون ان تطلب منهم حتى التوقف
عن السير وعبرت الناشطه عن حزنها قائله ان
السيطره النظام الايراني على البلاد تعني
ان الحياه والتنفس تعتبران في نظره جارمه
في موضوع اخر لفت منظمه الطاقه الذريه
الايرانيه اي اتفاق على تركيب كاميرات
جديده في المنشات النوويه وقال المتحدث
باسم المنظمه الايرانيه انه لم يحدث اي
نقاش او اتفاق مع وفد مفتش الوكاله
الدوليه الذي زار ايران مؤخرا لتركيب هذه
الكاميرات وكان المدير العام للوكاله
الدوليه لطاقه الذريه رفيع اكد بعد عودته
من ايران انها وافقت على اعاده تشغيل
كاميرات مراقبه في عده مواقع نوويه وزياده
وتيره عمليه التفتيش اعتزم وزير الدفاع
الامريكي استون بدء جوله مرتقبه الى شرق
الاوسط خلال الايام المقبله وستشمل جوله
اوستن زياره لكل من اسرائيل ومصر والاردن
وبحسب مسؤولينا في البنغون سيحظى ملف
التهديدات الايرانيه والتنسيق الاقليمي
لمواجهتها باهميه كبرى خلال مباحثات هدف
الزياره الى دعم وتعزيز التعاون مع القاده
في منطقه الشرق الاوسط كما سي بحث خلال
جولته تصاعد العنف بين الفلسطينيين
والاسرائيليين وسبل ضمان الامن والاستقرار
في المنطقه
للاسبوع التاسع على التوالي يحتاج
الاسرائيليون ضد خطه تغيير النظام القضائي
الذي تقوم به حكومه رئيس الوزراء بنيامين
نتنياهو وتظهر المقاطع احتشاد الالاف في
الشوارع واغلاقها وفي اخر انباء المظاهرات
اعتقلت الشرطه اربعه اشخاص في تل ابيب
باعتبارهم ينتهكون النظام العام
[موسيقى]
في محاوله اسرائيليه لاحتواء الغضب
الامريكي قال رئيس الوزراء بنيامين
نتنياهو ان وزير الماليه لم يقصد المسافه
بالابرياء حين دعا لمحوي بلده حوار
الفلسطينيه
جاء ذلك في الوقت الذي تبحث واشنطن عن
منحي او منح وزير الماليه من زيارتها
الاسبوع المقبل بعد اتهامه بالتحريض على
العنف وارتكاب جرائم حرب
يبدا رئيس وزراء العراق محمد شاه السوداني
زياره الى مصر للقاء عدد من كبار
المسؤولين في اطار دعم العلاقات الثنائيه
بين البلدين واشارت وسائل الاعلام محليه
الى ان الزياره المرتقبه سيكون بها توقيع
الاتفاقيات والعديد من مذكرات التفاهم بين
الدولتين مضيحه ان السوداني سيبحث العديد
من الملفات من بينها التبادل التجاري
ومشروع الربط الكهربائي والنفط والغاز
وزياده نسب الاستثمار المتبادل بين العراق
ومصر وحول هذا الموضوع ينضم الينا من
القاهره مراسل العربيه احمد عثمان اهلا بك
احمد يعني ما المعلومات المتوفره حتى الان
حول هذه الزياره التوقيت والشخصيات التي
سيلقاها
في انتظار اعلان وصول لرئيس الوزراء
العراقي الى مصر هذه الزياره معلنه منذ
ايام فيما يتعلق بالشق السياسي هي الزياره
الاولى على مستوى الثنائي هو كان قد التقى
مع الرئيس عبد الفتاح السيسي في عمان وتم
ايضا في بغداد هناك من يرى بان هذا هو
استكمال لما يراه البعض او ما يراه محللون
بالانفتاح العراقي على المحيط العربي
والذي بدا في عهد سلفه السيد مصطفى
الكاظمى كما ذكرتي بالفعل هذه الزياره
تحمل اكثر من عنوان ربما العنوان
الاقتصادي هو الابرز فيها فيما يتعلق
بالعلاقات الثنائيه فيما يتعلق بامور مثل
النفط والغاز في التبادل التجاري الرابط
الكهربائي كان الكثير من هذه الامور تم
مناقشتها خلال الحكومه السابقه برئاسه
السيد مصطفى الكاظمي وهناك ربما رغبه في
استكمارها او ربما تطويرها فيما يتعلق
بالوضع الاقتصادي المصري وايضا الوضع
الاقتصادي في الاقليم هناك ايضا من يرى
بان هناك جانب امني في العلاقه ما بين
البلدين فيما يتعلق بمواجهه الارهاب
وغيرها وايضا فيما يتعلق بالتنسيق فيما
يتعلق بالتحديات التي تواجه المنطقه بشكل
عام فيما يتعلق بالجزء الاخير من سؤالك
فمن المفترض ان يكون هناك بالتاكيد لقاء
مع الرئيس عبد الفتاح السيسي وربما سيكون
هناك مؤتمر صحفي وتوقيع عدد من مذكرات
التفاهم حيث علمنا بان الوفد العراقي يدوم
مجموعه كبيره من الوزراء ايضا كان هناك
معلومات بانه قد يكون هناك زياره الى
مشيخه الازهر ولقاء مع الامام احمد الطيب
الامام الاكبر كان من المفترض ان يكون
هناك ايضا زياره الى جامعه الدول العربيه
ولقاء مع السيد احمد ابو الغيط امين ولكن
اخترنا بان هذه الزياره تم الغاءها بسبب
ضغط جدول الاعمال المتعلق بزياره رئيس
الوزراء العراقي الى القاهره
نعم شكرا جزيلا لك اذا من القاهره احمد
عثمان مراس العربيه
ميليشيات الحوثي على هدم محلات تجاريه في
العاصمه اليمنيه صنعاء لعدم دفع جيبايات
باهظه كما احتجزوا ملاك المحلات في سجن
مديريه
معينه وتداول ناشطون مقطعا مرئيا يظهر
استخدام ميليشيات الحوثي جرافه كما نرى
بهذه الصور جرافه لهدم محلات الحميده في
شارع الستين ضمن حمله واسعه طالت العشرات
من المحلات والاسواق التجاريه قناه حكومه
تايوان انه على الصين احتراما التزام
الشعب التايواني بالمفاهيم الاساسيه
لسياده والديمقراطيه والحريه واوضح بيان
مجلس شؤون السياسه الصينيه في تايوان ان
على الصين معالجه الامور عبر مضيق تايوان
بطريقه عمليه وعقلانيه
ومتساويه ومحترمه لطرفين
جاء ذلك ردا على تصريحات رئيس الوزراء
الصيني لكتشيونج الذي اكد سعيا بلاده
لتعزيز اعاده التوحيد السلمي مع تايوان
وطلب باتخاذ خطوات حازمه لمعارضه استقلال
تايوان مشيرا الى تمسك بكين بمبدا الصين
واحده الذي ينص على ان تايوان جزء من
الصين ترفض حكومه تايوان بشده طبعا
مطالبات بكين بالسياده وتقول ان سكان
الجزيره فقط من يمكنهم تقرير مستقبلهم
واعلنت طاء الصين رفعه ميزانيتها العسكريه
بنسبه 7.2% لهذا العام في تسارع طفيف
مقارنه بالعام الماضي وجار الاعلان عن هذا
المعدل وهو اعلى مما كان عليه عام 2022
7.1% في تقرير لوزاره الماليه وتخطط بكين
لانفاق نحو 225 مليار دولار على دفاعها اي
اقل بثلاث مرات من ميزانيات واشنط
ن الامير هاري وزوجته قد يفقدان مكانا
خاصا لهما في حال عودتهما للمملكه المتحده
وهذا بسبب قرار الملك تشارلز بطردهما من
منزلهما الرفي في الذي عرضه الملك تشارلز
على اخيه الامير اندرو للسكني فيه
الامير هاري وزوجته ميجان ميركل سيطردان
من منزلهما الريفي
رغم انفاقهما الملايين على ترميمه فهل
سيستردان بعض هذه الاموال الخبراء يقولون
في احلامهما
المقر المكون من عشر غرف نوم كان هديه
الملك الراحله اليزابيث الثانيه لهاي
وميجن بعد حفل زفافهما عام 2018
لينتقل اليه الزوجان لفتره محدوده عقب
ولاده طفلهما الاول
وسرعان ما ذهب للعيش في ولايه كاليفورنيا
بعد تحررهما من قيود الملكيه في عام 2020
املا في بناء حياه ومهن جديده
ودعى العرش ومعه فروج موركوتيج وكذلك
ملايين الدولارات لم يستخدم الزوجان مقر
اقامتهما في خلال مكوثهما في امريكا الا
في مناسبات قليله ورغم انهما انفقا ثلاثه
ملايين و200 الف دولار على تجديده وترميمه
الا انهما معرضان للطرد وعدم استرداد تلك
المبالغ
يبدو ان هذا سيكون ثمنا باهضا مقابل
اصرارهما على حياه طبيعيه
جرد الملك تشارلز الثالث ابنه الامير هاري
وزوجته ميجا ماركل من فروج مور كوتيج في
الحادي عشر من يناير بعد يوم من نشر هاري
مذكراته المثيره للجدل
التي انتقد خلالها افرد العائله الملكيه
بعد التلبيه رئيس هيئه الترفيه السعودية
تركي الشيخ نداء الطفل السوري اليتيم ربيع
وصل الطفل الحالم الى الرياضه وزاره نادي
النصر السعودي وحقق حلمه بلقاء اللاعبه
المفضل كريستيانو رونالدو
من نفق ظلام دامس الى نور الرياض ونصرها
[موسيقى]
ربيع طفل سوريا اليتيم بعيون براقه وضحكه
خجول والحلم لقاء لاعب نادي النصر السعودي
كريستيانو رونالدو
ففي زياره للبعثه الاماراتيه لمناطق
الزلزال نطق لسان هذا الطفل باحلامه ووصل
صوته للسعوديه
وبعباره يا ولد ابشر لبى رئيس هيئه
الترفيه تركي ال الشيخ النداء وفي اقل من
اسبوعين وصل ربيع الى رياض حلمه وزار نادي
النصر والتقى بلاعبه المفضل
وعيون الطفل الحالم تكاد لا تصدق ما تراه
في مباراه النصر من داخل الملعب
[موسيقى]
الى العناوين
القوات الروسيه تقترب من حسم معركه بخموت
وزعيم فاجنر يدعو زيلينسكي لاخراج
المدنيين
وزير الدفاع امريكا في جوله شرق اوسطيه
والبنتاجون لا يستبعد الخيار العسكريه ضد
ايران
وسط تمديد دوليا دعوات لاحتجاجات واسعه ضد
النظام الايراني بسبب مسلسل تسمم فتيات
المدارس
الصين تدعو لاعاده التوحيد السلمي مع
تايوان والاخيره ترد بضروره احترام حريه
شعبها
الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]